[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
opportunity dances with those on the
dance floor where America's Got Talent
is right there in New England six and oh
sheesh this is the be our vetting show
presented by the Caesars Palace Sports
Club
she is our betting insider Kelly Martha
Stewart and I'm cami Richards best bet
cash with the Broncos plus five now we
didn't even need the points Denver
outright winner those are my favorite
kind of bats cats yes yes we've now get
three best bets in a row improving our
season record two four and one and I've
got another one coming right up let's go
cabbie let's go
[Music]
let's start the marquee match its of the
week 49ers plus three and a half at the
Rams total fifty and a half we know Todd
Gurley is now out with a thigh contusion
but it doesn't matter the market hasn't
even moved kind of know that Gurley just
really hasn't been the same since last
fall and then you have the Niners see
who's finally gonna step up in class
lots of hype people think the Niners are
the best team in this division but I'm
not quite buying it they're opponents
combined records 5 and 15 on the season
coupled with the fact that the Rams have
some rest advantage I'm laying the three
here with LA Texans plus four at the
Chiefs total 55 the look-ahead line here
was Kansas City - 8 and a half prior to
losing to the Indianapolis Colts on the
Sunday I know that this Chiefs team is
still getting a lot of love and the
Texans seem to be the trendy dog of the
week months lots of sharp people
but Tyreke Hill is back here I do lean
towards the Chiefs - for here and Monday
night Lions plus 4 at the Packers total
45 guys want to be at the game if you
want to buy me a beer would love to say
hi to everyone
Detroit has won three straight versus
Green Bay and I'd love to say they might
win four but I might not ever get
invited back to Lambeau Field they have
covered four straight against the
Packers Stafford though 9 + 55 straight
up versus above 500 teams those two two
of those wins against Green Bay war
without Aaron Rodgers but I do think the
Lions keep it within a field goal let's
quickly recap the marquee matchups of
the week remember lean is not a game
that I'm personally betting but if you
insist on having some action that's the
direction of leaning towards we have the
Chiefs - four and then I have pics on
the Rams
- three and Alliance plus four you know
when you were in high school or in
college and you're working on a group
project and you're doing all of the
heavy lifting and your peers are
contributing very little to that project
yeah I've never had that experience okay
that's how I feel every week come with
me run on a field trip we are far less
all right
kaby
the people's parlay has just been
unacceptable you guys are all in five on
the season and I want to help you
because I know how much this means to
you so I got an idea
[Music]
you need better people how about a
legend you can help me with the People's
Party absolutely not
you're 1/5 I don't want that part of my
record but I have some people that will
help you so I need some help with a
couple of winless teams Washington and
Miami to be honest man I have a gut
feeling I know the Redskins gonna win
this week Dallas Cowboys are playing in
New York versus the Jets the Cowboys are
gonna win for sure because even though
the Jets are at home their defense is
not ready for an explosive offense Oh
[Music]
Washington is owned five Miami is owned
for somebody's got to win who wins this
game who's gonna be their quarterback
don't take it personal yeah how you
gonna make points with the Redskins team
with all these quarterback issues this
is the people's problem chilly enough to
Kelly Portland do you have any tattoos
of football teams on your body no no
many tats
Oh obviously that almost leaves are only
44 Pittsburgh I pally Chargers I'm going
for Tigers Dallas the New York Jets
Sandara is returning from on Olivia Brad
mano Roma the people's parlay is own
five I don't want to fall to own six I
really like you're gonna help write this
[ __ ] okay make football bets are you
more of a gut feeling guy you come on
the line for me
good got feel it's pure guy yeah yeah
slave it away you guys just ask people
with their gut says the Cowboys at the
New York Jets from New York you are from
New York yeah you being from New York I
just got to lean more towards them and
say you don't want I think they're gonna
pull it what are your thoughts I know
maybe I'm Bale to be is still one of the
best if not one of the top three running
back to the NFL you just recap your
picks for us again jerks Steelers doll
Dallas Cowboys they travel to New York
to play the Jets I am a Cowboys fan
they've gotten embarrass last two weeks
by good teams
yes buggy teams but Dallas should one
both of those games
Pittsburgh Los Angeles I think I'm gonna
shoot or the Steelers
this Steelers team that I like I do
think this is a lot of points but it's a
scary event for sure think about more
things to think about Washington at
Miami
both teams are looking for their first
win who wins this game Redskins
Washington doesn't matter that they just
fired their head coach this week I think
that might be motivation for them to do
better
yo okay all right I like it China what's
on your sleeve just out of curiosity my
life story your life story
you get you won't have time and the
conclusion of the story dude does the
peoples parlay win in one week yeah it
does thanks Joe we do baby back
[Music]
people's parler might actually earn its
first winning ticket but I doubt a
cabbie here's someone more of my mix for
week six when I start off with the
Saints plus three at the jacks total 42
this one's been bet way up I played Jags
moneyline - 125 earlier on in the week
but I still really like this Jack's team
we know both teams are thriving with
backup quarterbacks but that
Jacksonville defense is going to bring
Teddy Bridgewater back down to earth
Jaguars
- 155 Texans plus 1 and a half at the
Broncos total 51 we talked about this
Broncos team last week this team could
very easily be 3 and 2 instead of 1 & 4
they got the win for us last week they
have some common traits their belt and
they want to get a win at home a loss of
two games at home on last-second field
goals this season
Broncos is a better play at - 125 on the
money line they're taking the one and a
half Falcons - two and a half at the
Cardinals total 51 and a half 52 in some
spots we talked about this Falcon seemed
last week as well what is going on in
Atlanta Matt Ryan's fantasy owners love
him Kelly and Vegas not so much Lana
eight and 13 in their last 21 games this
team just hasn't been right since it's
the Super Bowl 51 collapse Cardinals win
this game allow me to run through the
off the offense of the Mons an probably
ideal like when you speak in third
person
Kelly will answer the vetting question
sent to us from our bleacher report
audience first up is Mike Baker he wants
to know is it ever recommended to buy
points if so when and how many points
let's take this as a learning
opportunity mr. Mike Baker learned from
my mistakes
I've made a lot of them in my decade in
this industry I used to buy the hook I
got a lot of grief for it on social
media so I started really researching
and when should you be buying Keena off
key numbers 3 and 5 or so I'm sorry 3
and 7 are the only two times I can
recommend that to buy off three and a
half to three and off seven and a half
to seven since the extra point moved
back we have seen five weighing more
than one two and four but I still don't
recommend buying off those numbers and
me personally instead of weighing two
and a half or buying off the
two and a half or anything of that
nature you might as well just play the
money line as I suggested in the Denver
Broncos game Alex Smith asks what's it
gonna take for people to realize that
betting in the Cleveland Browns is just
a bad idea regardless of line value
hashtag avoid trash teams Oh
hashtag I like that one Alex you know
this line open Cleveland's minus two on
Sunday night what happens Cleveland gets
thrashed by the Niners and they feel
getting more grief on social media than
me the Browns are the play today why
because when their stock goes low that's
time to buy the whole world is on the
sea oxygen looks a little too good to be
true
Steve coffee ass you said that you bet
the numbers and not the team's what
percentage of your bets are based on the
number and then what percentage is based
on your handicap a bad game Joey yes
absolutely rebutting numbers here not
teams because if we went off the names
of the teams on the Jersey we'd always
be betting the best teams and those
teams tend to be overvalued but if you
want me to break down the map and go
down the rabbit hole I will six out of
every hunter NFL bats have a ten percent
margin of value of the closing line so
it is really only about six percent of
the times as the masks come in to play
of course we look at different things
you look at the matchup we look at
coaching edges situational edges turns
and angles motivation but yes I do bet
numbers not teams all of those things
play into that as well you guys ready
it's now time for part two of the
peoples parlay
[Music]
[Music]
Johnson I come bearing gifts thank you
what do we got here this is the bearing
gifts play we have Washington
there's cowboy though Dallas is on there
the Steelers are on there let me just
check to make sure we got the K so
Washington minus four and a half
Dallas minus seven and the Pittsburgh
Steelers plus six this is our peoples
parlay Kelly you think what not gonna
hit every week it goes two and one
where's printing money baby
all right listen let's make them let's
make the people some more racks Kelly
give him your best bet
[Music]
we cashed again last week with the
Broncos plus five-and-a-half putting it
at 4 and 1 on the season in my best bet
this week the Minnesota Vikings - three
and a half why because this guy right
here you guys see all the hard emojis
going around his face I love this man
why because he is one of the best ATS
coaches in the country especially at
home as a favorite 16 and 5 it gets a
spread and they're the last 21 games
when weighing 5 or less at home Kelly
Kirk Cousins isn't good against good
teams I'm not sold on that Eagles team
Vikings - three and a half you guys
ready to recap all of my picks for week
six these are listed in order of
confidence on how many units I'd
recommend you bet on each we've got our
first four unit plays of the season on
the Vikings the Rams and the Jags
remember the unit is your standard bet
amount it should be 1% of your bankroll
we have three units on the Browns
Alliance two units on the Broncos and
the Cardinals job had what you think of
my love affair here with coach Zimmer I
know you some time with him here or with
him in Cincinnati your thoughts
I love Zimmer he's a he's a I hate using
the word knucklehead of a coach but he's
a coach that will tell you things that
you don't want to get nobody he's done
other deeps of players like that okay
and I like he couldn't take chances yes
he's brought forward he's gone for
speaking of the Vikings a couple of
weeks ago Kirk Cousins publicly
apologized to his receiver Adam Thielen
for not getting him enough targets what
do you think of that as a former Kirk
Cousins never apologized to the receiver
you want to thank him or apologize to
him throw him the ball the following
game that is the best apology you can
give have you ever had a quarterback
publicly apologize to you for not
getting you enough time Carson Palmer no
no I was always open so Carson I had no
problems or issues thank you so much to
Chad Johnson for stopping by thank you
guys at home for joining us on the V are
vetting show presented by the Caesars
Palace sports book journey on social
life the artist or betting Chuck might
mix and yours good luck and we'll see
you guys next week
we're gonna hit finally the ball
[Music]
[Music]
you